mister jones professeur associé de
politique à l'université de montfort de
leicester c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir bonsoir alister
jones merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france avant je crois qu'on peut
parler ce soir clairement de de volte
face de boris johnson qui a annoncé une
stratégie bien à lui finalement il se
range à la stratégie du reste de
l'europe n'y aura pas de break site sur
ce sujet il fait comme les autres
comment l'expliquer je ne pense pas
qu'il va aussi loin que les autres sur
le continent il renforce progressivement
les mesures
il explique acquisitions si de ce qu'ont
fait nos preuves scientifiques
conseillent des scientifiques voilà ce
qu'il suit voilà ce qu'il applique donc
les experts d'après conseillé d'abord
changer nos habitudes comme vous laver
les mains plus sérieusement de ne pas
serrer la main de tout de même changé
des sages c'est le petit chemin pour un
site avec l'augmentation du nombre de
cas et des décès ils ont annoncé une
nouvelle mesure dès vendredi
toute chose les écoles seront fermées
les écoles privées indépendantes ont
reçu également des requêtes en ce sens
il ne s'agit pas d'une solution on
demande aux gens de ne pas sortir dans
les restaurants mais il n'a pas encore
dit je que les restaurants et les cafés
devraient fermer se navre suscite de la
colère parce que on perd des clients et
pourtant il faut toujours payer toutes
les factures
comment réagissent les britanniques avec
c
et atermoiements parce qu'effectivement
on ferme les écoles
dans le même temps ferme pas les cafés
est ce que
vos compatriotes ne voient pas là une
forme d'incohérence et peut-être
d'imprudence quand même quand on voit ce
qui se passe en italie et même en france
à
c'est difficile à dire
johnson a remporté les élections
générales et a promis d'obtenir le
brésil et il a toujours beaucoup de
succès auprès du de la population active
mans il ya de plus en plus deux avec
scepticisme gens peut-être que ce n'est
pas à la hauteur du travail
peut-être que je sais pas ce qu'il se
fait pour le moment on lui donne encore
le bénéfice du doute
je laissais de se représenter comme un
churchill du 21e siècle propose une
vision halak à un gouvernement très fort
il essaye de se présente on comme aux
manettes ce qu'on me contrôlant les
événements même si le doigt dessus rétro
dans un mode de réaction les universités
le nhs pense qu une des places de la
hauteur qui ne sait pas ce qu'il fait et
qu'il faudrait se diriger vers un
confinement bien plus rapide comme dans
le reste de l'union européenne
alors il ya quand même une petite
différence il ya d'autres pays qui qui
font appel à des retraités mais enfin le
gouvernement britannique demande d'aidé
des pouvoirs extraordinaires permettant
tout de même des arrestations à des fins
de santé publique ou effectivement la
mobilisation de deux retraités de
services médicaux que c'est bien
nécessaire ses pouvoirs extraordinaires
pour procéder à des arrestations pouvoir
existe s'ils ont besoin autres utilisées
par certains aspects nous sommes un peu
en retard par rapport au reste de
l'union européenne
mais par d'autres aspects le
gouvernement veut être prêt donc il doit
y avoir un confinement comme il ya dans
le reste de l'europe et le cas échéant
la police aura effectivement l'autorité
nécessaire pour arrêter le
revenant certaines personnes ont exprimé
leur préoccupation disant que les
britanniques vont obéir au début puis
cela c est essayer de continuer leur vie
ordinaire donc c'est pouvoir existeront
déjà pour empêcher ce cas de figure
donc c'est ce sont des pouvoirs qui sont
adoptées au kazoo et pas pour une
utilisation directe
comment réagissent les britanniques par
ailleurs sur cette inquiétude déjà il y
avait une incertitude quand même lié au
break citons il ya beaucoup de thèse en
économie est ce que voilà le break site
va enrichir appauvrir il y avait
beaucoup d'incertitudes à ce sujet là et
maintenant ses conséquences économiques
très importantes aussi lié aux
coronavirus ce que les britanniques
craignent de pas forcément s'en remettre
est ce parce que le brésil est vraiment
éclipsé pour le moment on a presque
oublié cette histoire ce n'est plus le
sujet pour beaucoup de personnes nombre
exact c'est terminé on put l'union
européenne a à la fin de l'année le 1er
janvier on sera complètement distincts
de l'union européenne donc c'est réglé
il s'agit là maintenant d'une autre 6
les gens se posent des questions
s'inquiètent à propos de leur vie de
tous les jours ils se demandent si leur
entreprise vont survivre et ne se pose
pas trop de questions au niveau
gouvernemental de l'état la réaction est
donc assez atténuées les personnes ne
sont pas extrêmement préoccupés parce
que cette image générale leur échappe il
se sentait plutôt à propos des détails
de leur vie quotidienne vont ils réussir
à payer leurs factures s'ils sont
indépendants pourront c'est continuer à
travailler le gouvernement va-t-il
pouvoir les aider
s'agissant du soutien proposé par le
talent n'avait encore aucune information
origines sun a promis beaucoup d'argent
mais pour le moment
les gens ne se tournent pas vers cette
solution parce que ça n'est pas encore
une nécessité donc quand à savoir ce qui
va arriver c'est difficile à dire
en tout cas cela puisse faire à l'idée
c'est qu'on est con à deux ou trois
semaines de retard vis-à-vis du reste de
l'europe en termes de corona virus donc
les gens se posent plus de questions
chez jean phi quotidienne par exemple si
l'on se rend dans un supermarché il ya
beaucoup d' étagères gould parce que
beaucoup de personnes commencent à faire
des réserves
sous l'effet de la panique no kill the
pros explique qu pas du reste du pays
mais de même merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous alister
jones en direct de l'ice et leicester
merci